the name Turkey it's not going to be the
paper that she is going to comment which
is much better in many ways and controls
either just very quickly introduce all
our contributors to the panel and right
next to meters in that order is Anunnaki
who is from the Institute of Islamic
studies of the russian academy of
sciences he focuses on the Cold War
especially in Eastern Europe includes
obviously the Balkans yes especially
written about the split between I think
that some of our successful in being
Tito and studied but also in the way in
which this then interacts with the
policy and strategies of the United
States
next to him is sinew bones again very
quickly as you probably already know I
think the most recent publication is
well together before the surface of
course the dictionary of 20 century
communism the other publications they
Center on the history of the Cold War
but also the dutiful period the Cold War
I should say that means the beginning
at least if you see the full scope here
business beginning and also its end and
of course yes
also on the Italian Communist Party and
has joined us to their from the
university is also contributed mentally
to the chemistry of the and then next
who is working at university about us
and also times associated with the
network of European studies University
off and simply she specializes also on
of course the Cold War but in Europe and
in South Eastern Europe in the broken so
I should say be pristine services
correct and I think her latest
publication if I'm not mistaken is Mount
alignment and its origins in and it
actually relates the cases of Yugoslavia
and Finland and now I would like to just
pass the word
three years of great yourself during
policy in the Mediterranean region you
must define a special treat release
condition we guarantee concepts of the
prior service period and understand the
extent of influence the bolshevik I
doubled it and this will allow the
understand the character of Soviet
Union's perception of the publishers the
main participants of the year will be
difficult
keeps and USA as well as the use of
starvation to the shifting environment
on European and international levels you
know the simpler Russia took notice of
the eastern Mediterranean in the second
half of an item salary which what is
decreasing might demand inclusion of the
new Slavic countries in security because
these expansions to not only the
missionary ITM of saving brother scraps
from the Turkish yogurt but mostly
practical goal 35
position in this report of such
ingenuity the main target was to
establish we'd imposes traits an issue
level with Russia and also with quickly
the powers that has always observed the
region as part of his field of interest
the Russian British competition has
immediate training continued until in
the first century demonstrating
assistance in students from the two
powers to be better teachers revolution
of the late Senator introduce a certain
changes to the foreign policy of Russia
while maintaining the former regimes me
here political directors legalistic
Bolshevik government headed by later
expressed the issue of national borders
through the please moral revolution
expensing if to very secure the Kremlin
he must create the training to support
the additional forces but it's previous
loss of in Bulgarian to keep at the
beginning consequences but only limited
financial support the Commission
computer allowed the Soviet government
to start developing a new Bolshevik
strategy on world domination
was based on increasing the influence of
left-wing political powers and Eastern
European countries preaching popular
fruits for the sake of the future
countries double power for more - and
this attack of Nazi Germany okay mr.
attention to the rotating however its
rejection is the first Western countries
would become palace and signing an
agreement with Japan in an attempt to
work world of the Nazi sweet Moscow
along with Berlin became a participant
of the divisional zoo society so give an
extra moment with the survivor and was
officiating did not say over the over
the Straits June 1941 first started to
change his guidelines and join forces
with
the very first negotiation who is even
in Moscow on December 1941 sure that
that despite a serious tree coming from
to me trembling tried to remain human in
his position concerning the western and
eastern borders of the Soviet state in
the decision this evening
Scalia the positive named Romanian
Slovak all companionship and Turkey as a
country they wanted to see in the Soviet
field of security after the war
practically repeating the phony
political priorities of cherished Russia
of the on the Balkans and in the black
districts a single committee created an
open
copy in 1943 of the people's chemistry
about foreign affairs including a
committee of regulations and what were
pieces of regulation began development
have to tell it so different political
plans for instance and the committee of
preparation headed by Iman my scheme
issued a document the dress to Molotov
in January 1944 and to document ID is a
political system transformation were
development for hostile and presently
occupied countries based on principles
of pro-democracy it's the spirit of the
ideals of Popular Front
among the countries under which the
various medicine
outside intubation we're going to be
used to create extra democratic regimes
with Romania Bulgaria Yugoslavia
regional planning the function of
external influence was to be handed by
users our USA and England for the first
time and diplomatic documents describing
first world order and the prospects of a
certain politics the puffers tried to
proceed from the
the tensions between American future
political reasons this would have led to
English Russian relationships improving
t to the main confrontation the struggle
with us a further development that
ceases that possible Emmons so truth
drawn before my speech brought after
water that after was used to sell only
interested in preserving England as a
great power with a strong level to be
because such an imminent may be useful
to balance interface of USA in
catalystic expansion and interesting
effect is a certainty climatic referring
to dynamic introduced perfect agree we
as a country conservative empiricism as
opposed to the anything traditional
given same principles supporters and
competence of the Soviet politics
including it politics and the subject
confusion in the subject of preventing
the formation define it as the political
goal for this politics was further
discussed in the series of lucify the
can be cheated by vaccinate in one of
them was TPP prospects of the Soviet
occupation defining is a few so creature
is of the two cultures in sweetmary as a
measure to come to an after staining
with creature conscious located
as well as one must eat of the desired
process it was suggested to guarantee
the integrity of the teller Italy syrupy
possessions including civilians
something expose its positions plain
what makes you part in this equation
leaving the fact of the fate of colonies
to be
you see a year and half later on the
verge of the postal conference the end
of June 1945 the position comes the
superpowers change to presented to the
west allis with clearly defined demands
concerning public with each new
far-reaching strategic plans and Rosco
was not hoping to realize the maximum
you know we're sending a chocolate of
the letter title to receiving
territories under trusteeship
recommended receiving at least part of
zento B and E's Islands jurisdiction
should be halted spelling and his
conversation with him in 1941 suggested
passing therefore between Turkey to
attack the Philips main argument was
closing Spanish - gracias traits which
was of greatest importance to the user
self-esteem emphasized for defying
position of silence will make possible
three packs into the Mediterranean and
after shoes into the teenagers will be
received by shipping over there
position educated we're not waiting to
part with his mandate for the table he
be assistant which would allow according
to the field to start filming and
subpoena of the Mediterranean so must
performing the real battle with Western
palates at the second couple forties
during the first session of the council
of ministers of Foreign Affairs water
proclaim uses our preparedness putting
trust you see for believers webpart
Celtic where the presence of two levels
and Air Force Base is there any
treatment motive trade to use the Soviet
Union is need to have masses which
merchant fleet in the military as an
army the posture performance that USSR
wasn't going to enforce a Soviet
political system and be there you know
private document title on three four
Italian possibly written by Stalin
himself it was recommended in the
directive stone
Soviet military ships in limited numbers
it was written and numbers well to be
able to talk and force of this part of
Eden to reach is go multiple tests to
propose a deal to register meeting with
Bevin Cartman and agreement grant you
start a base in the military in the
return for passing the 30 pennies
islands to piece some civilian was
interesting he reminded the Moscow
repeating is demand for Constantinople
the government promises to the first how
the mode of failure to tertiary fruition
administered to accept suspect remise
demonstrators as the British government
fears the facility over situation is
immediate range that we divide that
which is in part into so when steer
assistant Moscow is present the region
known is a certain tactics of the
supporting families visited mr. Gribble
it was Sultan powering it to
intermediate Iranian would end in a
similar it is not that securities
including schedule or the study came
upon they've managed to fortified
position in those parts on the popular
regions the theaters for a pioneer for
valium and Yugoslavia most will never
match be balanced in other parts of the
military this region let itself to suit
yourself
face such a serious country the Soviet
Union Fushimi with its motto developer
offering various forms of support and
teacher situation returned with years
for soon replace it because ten
confrontation is again it is possible to
study after encountering such a stubborn
reaction
really to survey the constantly the
world was for Satori's training is that
harder than settle for supreme leader
clearly hunter studious countries true
for appearance's the scope of the
country student ruins he realizes when
to be greedy for immediate reckless
schemes that could result in serious
losses the number world circles she
spoke of the need for a peaceful rest
lasting 15 20 years a sudden successful
revolution in china possibility to
consider mind-boggling to any possible
setting in tourism on fire from for the
fire
what I'm trying to do is to follow
polypharmacy - Rania I will essentially
focus on the case of USSR agent
relations in the context and I think
this is not simply case study but it's
the center of the central point of
Soviet relations after Stalin's death
after up to the end of the 1960's but
and obviously here the central problem
is how and why the Soviet search for
influence eventually fade after a final
television reaching its apex in the
aftermath of a six-day war taken to this
function of the Soviet Union from my
mind and understanding of such problem
entails acknowledging that after study
States Soviet views and policies towards
them to learn and change it underwent a
substantial change it is a point at
which to space for discussion
I think remarkable ingenuity and I can
change the merger the long two
tendencies the first one was no morphine
simply as a key region for solid
security interests in Balkans and in
strays but also as a crucial link to
North Africa and released as playing a
role in the competition through west
over the conquest of the phosphonium
world
second point the establishment of Soviet
presence in the region became a
strategic goal to be achieved by
military as well by military means
whereby political economic and
diplomatic so under both aspects the
so-called Soviet rediscovered an
apparent in part because of the
proximity of religion you see
is offered by decolonization now the
Mediterranean evolved to more complex
motions and security and warfare
everywhere employed in established
tradition aliases with with anti anti
imperialist Nationals the fourth to is
point two minutes of Soviet of Tel Aviv
modernity chances to exercise influence
by completely promoting state building a
totalization
she seemed to be particularly promising
without the south east Mediterranean
countries always imply new challenges
against Western imperialism combination
I think it was a specificity here but
should not be lost like that by just
establishing analogies with the past and
the factors of continuity which is based
on recent question there is a point in
the memories by current rooted who was a
central for it official policy making
motivating long-lasting states venture
at the point he stays better Soviet
expansion into a so-called warmer sound
began in the Middle East but I think
there may be some overvaluation in such
it's such a change in policy even more
we short a colonization nevertheless I
think that you consume our should be
taken into account to some extent
because in fact women into ramen special
and I think in this respect those even
even Moscow approach man with Tito
should be considered important and
because of its multiple implications of
operation competition and mutual
containment especially the programming
but I believe is pointed in so let's
let's focus on Egypt
I think historians have often presented
with partnership between the Soviet
Union an agent and an obvious choice in
terms of foreign policy often so
important
Shapiro first statement of
19:56 about aging as we clean of
American imperialism in the Arab world
there was the dynamics fueled by
decolonization so the argument goes
propelling great powers to provide
responses that will expand the sphere of
action which was particularly for Soviet
Union in fact because the Suez Crisis
the second of relations all of these if
not all of these cannot be disputed
I think the sorry choices look more
ambitious than simply feeling a
geopolitical bathroom or following
cheerfully
because we are the answer in a service
was a kind of parody of a broader
audience with anti-terrorist national
and this resumed a no-bullshit
occasioned by effect we never really
developed it with nineteen twenties and
then later left apart by style what was
awarded conviction that the link between
national liberal community would work
much better in an increasingly
decolonized world and under the aegis of
solid so in a few years
Cairo became Center where representative
OH
the national liberation movements
grouped at 42 Soviet officials to the
aliens purpose the Egyptian Communist
Party was easily sacrifice sacrifice by
Moscow even more mana had been decades
in the nineteen twenties in Turkey much
more when our third world pro-soviet
leader might like Tsukiyama selfs regime
widely requested proper communists why
allow the building relations in the
Soviet Union but also to some extent
embracing Soviet models at the very
beginning of 1960s political and
symbolic meaning here should not be on
one side of course Egypt was central to
solve it interests in the Mediterranean
despite complaints about anti communist
aggression and tension created by the
unification between Egypt and Syria and
a third way the role of an advisor for
the entire network of information this
on one side on the other side.now
service was more committed than to shop
in supporting land area and he is
nationalist rhetoric you look
increasingly socialist in home
for example well everybody knows you
naturally program of nationalization
defined very social but he also said
what is even more rather than that I
think has been overlooked by historians
in the context of solid foreign policy
respect the partnership between two
sovereign and the same became
potentially even more crucial in the
aftermath of the Cuban crisis while
relations with Castro were painful and
circle those witness a more or less
stable more important the exit strategy
agreed between two sovereign Kennedy
involve entertaining would be
interpreted in Moscow as a deal about
influence also for Washington and after
all if I attempted to expand Soviet
intervention to layton America proved to
be happy realistic the Mediterranean a
gallop or five promise you have the
national revolutionary perspective
so I think from the documents like no
but are not so many because also easy
taking undertaking the importance of
crucial visit to Cairo in a 64 is it's
been very much underlined it was
probably the most important to be
solving in international affairs what is
more interesting it's family
self-reported and in his report he
stressed with progressive policy or
Egyptian leaders that he identified it
as populist more Mormon socialism but
nevertheless and at the same time he
blamed the communist parties for for
their dogmas about religion nationally
and criticized the Syrian Communist
leader Khaled - for having spoken
against I think
I think here despite the weakness of the
other communist movement what's
happening what's happening in the
Communist world should not be
disregarded at all because by led by
this time the parties including Lee
compared to the idea of an audience
after many years in urban areas with
Nationals after many years of reluctance
and sectarianism as well and in 1965 we
achieve self communist movement to work
this resolves itself to join the self
socialist Union must be incorporated to
his regime this wood was intended to
provide the kind of model and at the
same time I think they feel stories
right about them
there was an activity over two major
European colonies back in French
battalion policy in North Africa and I
don't know almost nothing about the
French also because we are kind of also
easily available but from the types of
attire correspond quite clear how
important the influence of the Italian
Communist Party in the reorientation of
our community
more toward an audience with national
such a kind of perspective like national
way so what was the was an interaction
between South European communist party
parties and North Africa that should not
be neglected intersection there is an
important concern of this kind of is
part of the story because all of East
was coordinated to some extent with
Moscow and all of this meant that
political and support role of the
Mediterranean in some way could be
expected to represent a laboratory for
combination between anti-western
nationalist and communist a central
point to Cecilia the pasta starving
strategy furthermore and here also a
potential development and a particular
significance at the time and Soviet
influence in Asia main ask me necessity
people ask because because of Chinese is
please and China looked extremely active
towards third world countries as to and
I trip to Asia and Africa
there will be 64 and so and and when
into the Politburo about history-related
the same Amina say the same record i
ported early crucial free market that we
are a believer but do not understand
Chinese positions while sharing ours
so will the Soviet pragmatic line in
Macau was Arab nationalism but the
detrimental even before tea shops for in
on over 64
but despite the establishment of the new
leadership in Moscow there was the
remarkable continuity in some iterations
Egypt remain one of the new of a few
further lies of the Soviet Union after
the turning point of the mean mid-1960s
in the fall of many many ways appeared
as we only reach our Moscow was able to
be in the ambiences while the socialist
can look to hopelessly broken
I think I have so what I wish to do now
is just to present some argument about
the Six Day War
how the Soviet Union approach of the war
despite the continuity of relations
between Egypt and the other other Arab
regimes Syria the American perception
which was increasingly strong or the
mountain solid many varied inter alia
was fight for the exaggerated in the
science back to Moscow aliens building
was more fragile than one would suppose
as it was exposed to the conduct of
radical and our reliable partners for
example mid-november 66 Romeo declare
that the Politburo is preoccupation
about the activity of Palestinian
extremists and strong influence in his
opinion by the Chinese again and he's
larger than Allah about China's a and
creating a second Vietnam we at least
this is probably overstated but shows
the Soviet preoccupation for the
stability of its own influence in the
region the Soviet Union did not exercise
control over our allies and part of
being able to restrain them
by political and diplomatic means would
follow the drastic moves and this is the
problem into the six
the idea that Moscow is edgy and Syria
to war seems like unconvincing in the
light of recent research and also
remembers by combining more plausibly
the Soviets emphasize Israel is less
than cherry in order to criticize
morning words of there are the lines
demonstrated by what is more relevant
here are the consequences of the six-day
war for the Soviet Union
the wall adapter marked the diplomatic
and political failure from nevertheless
it's aftermath appeared unexpectedly
encouraging for the rise of Soviet power
editor and I said a few minutes ago he
fell apart as everybody knows Moscow
engaged in negotiations with Washington
important service of its free finances
the military reconstruction of Egyptians
and Syrians armored forces and so on but
with Soviet political deficiencies were
not canceled the idea that permanent but
not explosive tension in the region
would work for the interests proved to
be ineffective fuel instead of
containing
national radical the break-up
populations with Tel Aviv was
contradictory he saw it criticism
of Arabic a radical opinion against the
existence of the State of Israel and
prevented Moscow from playing in danger
the military dependency of the Arab
regimes turned out into reciprocal
pressure from influence scarcely
function to the Soviet strategy of
control
whoa this was a typical dynamics or upon
world even in the Mediterranean the
outcome would be particularly damaging
for the Saudi King the world of tension
of 69 resulted in repeat of Soviet
military presence in Egypt and many
German was the first Soviet significance
in intervention outside the social scale
and of Prague to the interventions of
1970 but it was also a problem to the
veining authorities such a crucial life
of solitude in the third world like
Egypt was that to be lost in subsequent
years so we should conclude that the
meter running in the 1960s was a test
for the limits of Soviet power the
Soviet Union's search for influence
failed but we should ask what kind of
influence and why faith the point here
is that the combined efforts to build up
any Arab nationalist as an integral part
of a new strategy and to establish the
presence of solid powers that can be
there were probably several different
reasons for these that we can understand
my 9 own in the context of the Soviet
numerous global strategies first I think
the tendency to allow international
presence
Poliquin simply did not worry
despite of Attraction exercises by solid
meat and his two metal approach became
in fact reciprocal into beauty what
we're doing to weaken any solid
relationship agent formally department
the pattern number two Italian party
state enforcing organization but
necessary and no evolution control
second point Soviet policy making and
conduct where misoriented by polishing
building when by power politics and
ideological challenges this respect the
weight of a Chinese factor as not to be
overlooked because of its multiple of
portable implications in weakening the
compactness or the socialist camp
compelling Moscow to me the logic effect
the teacher any restraint in the space
of policy in other words being teammates
vulnerability and then the breakup of a
socialist can vary conditioning
conditioning aspect of Soviet policies
even further the next point the priority
given to military factors especially
after crucial for damaged political
economic and diplomatic means but we're
a very big models the Soviet powers
politic in politics in the Mediterranean
became an end in itself electrology
Monica capacity of the Soviet Union
clearly emerged in the relations with
Egypt well before sorry
ten years ago when I was very very young
one day I was working in Oxford after a
lecture my adviser
he seems very agitated we had been to a
guest lecture on the topic of communist
history of the Balkan states and he
hadn't asked anything which was very
rare in the leaving but if he seemed
agitated I asked him so what did you
think about the presentation and looked
at me and said in agreement they didn't
mention one time the Communist Party in
that whole presentation and that we
cannot do that we cannot just run away
from ourselves and having listened to
this conversation yesterday and today it
reminded me of that point that there can
really be no investigation or a history
of communism without the Communist Party
because it was very stern of on quality
single part of State and it reminded me
that we can not really have an
investigation of the Cold War without
the Soviet Union no cold war can be
actually that mobile that it doesn't has
the Soviet Union in it
and for that reason when we have talked
about the limits of Soviet
this really sub soviet intent in the
mediterranean I would like us to just to
pretend at that point sometimes to me it
seems that it is impossible to look at
the years between 1945 and maybe
1979-1989 without a Cold War
I understand that the Mediterranean is a
very layered region and there are
permanent US strategic interests and
there are questions of the Middle East
but I think the Cold War in some sense
remains and if there is no Cold War if
there is no Soviet Union think they're
really cool Kimiko pouring that area
that was just my point
we met reason I was very happy to come
to this panel today and I'm happy that
it's taken place a little bit earlier in
the day I'd like to suggest maybe one
reason why we come back to that point of
the there's limits of the Soviet
influence in the Mediterranean which
might not have to do protection we might
have to do with the history of refer to
Soviet Union that is just my comment to
this panel and I would like to suggest
that these two authors perhaps to me and
his personally represent some kind of
area post post revisionist is the
facility if we think about the history
or prety if it was worst about
totalitarian models and the one party
and have been burnt it was about
everyday life and the last favorite
between Easter was about the study of
the Soviet Borderlands and nationalities
when it is winter study of the Soviet
Forex target for
not very sexy not very Michael to get
your career afterwards if you do a
dissertation on this topic so I think
that that the study of Soviet foreign
policy was already in the next day not a
very favorite position when their
archives are open then what happened
with the partial opening of the archives
in the in the Soviet Union was something
that normally mark I think is very well
both Thea let the documents speak
approach where the Soviet foreign policy
was written directly from the documents
and very much about the documents
without a broader vision and introduced
a few interpretations about Soviet
foreign policy but they were very
focused on Eastern Europe according to
one for example they're very sort of a
favorite position or the strong stream
of literature from let's say 1995 to
today Moscow's foreign policy recently
the West Was pragmatic and it was about
political elites in Eastern Europe
others have argued that the so pay
attention on the over Eastern Europe and
the communist parties had already became
defined as a primary goal during the war
what I liked about these papers and what
I have always liked about the the entire
body of work of sylvio's and monotone
existed although they have worked in the
archives from the early 1990s amongst
some of the very first people to me this
work has asked different questions or
found slightly different answers to
these questions
for example anatoly's work has unified
the approach of effects of u.s. foreign
policy and
a foreign policy in Yugoslavia which is
a slightly different approach looking at
the same documents about Soviet foreign
policy that I think the trick we know
something more because it asks slightly
different questions
it doesn't answers that this paper and
the body of work comes up with does not
entirely put on finally those two
categories Silver's working like
nineteen early material or the
mid-nineteen ninety's talked about the
zombie to Europe Soviet Union and Europe
who 1942 anything 53 yes it was about
the style in this period but it was a
broader Europe
it wasn't the Warsaw Pact only and
wasn't only questions about the party so
that would be sort of mine that would be
my comment about the appreciation of a
body of work and what I hope to see here
as a kind of a post post division is
normal for Soviet history if I could
make a few specific points about the
papers to me one of the very interesting
points from the first paper had to do
with the simple 1945 41 Association so
it talks with Anthony Eden and the point
that he is so his sphere of security
already within or when it was photo at
that time included tremont Sweden Poland
Hungary Czechoslovakia Romania the
Parker Pen in solidarity I perhaps would
like to hear a bit more about that it
was
it's a strategic interest that maps out
a zone of security that clearly extends
all the way to the eastern Mediterranean
and I also was very interested in the
point and the documents about the Soviet
secret services not only focusing on
Germany Italy Japan but also on orbit
that was very interesting to me
and I feel like those are some
connecting points from the earlier
period that then perhaps connect to
space foreign policy
Silvio I just have one question which
was that dummy if if the main points
here is the PM that there was a turn
after Stalin's death to which the
policies in the Mediterranean and it is
great to ask if in the other thing and
then this turn was altered by Bhushan
for where the return provision h1 is it
strategic is it does it have to do with
weapons technology is it could serve as
a deterrent is this the moment where if
the history of the Soviet Union are wave
movements right there are moments of
dynamism followed by retrenchment so
we're starving is retrenchment
Miami is second policy-related really
watered by humans a political leader or
is it conditioning perhaps by the United
States technology I think maybe
something in the water